Ford versus Ferraris I mean it's in here
but it's not the point I mean it's not
not about that it's just not really
about there I am that's why we have
reviews so we can elaborate forward
versus Ferrari so Ford versus Ferrari is
the true story about gonna condense it
for you Ford was like we need to make a
change we need to get into the racing
game we need to beat Ferrari we're gonna
beat him in this insane race called
LeMans that they always win at Carroll
Shelby played by Matt Damon he's the guy
who's gonna get it done for us and Matt
Damon's like Ken miles played by
Christian Bale he's the guy's gonna get
it done with me that man is not wearing
hockey pads also the race at the end of
this movie takes place in 1966 so it's
all working towards that almost forgot
to mention that suppose it's kind of
important to let you know what year if
not decade the movie takes place and now
it's really two guys versus Ford versus
Ferrari
this is what I like about this movie
it's not really about the corporation of
Ford taking on the corporation of
Ferrari or the CEO of Ford taken on the
CEO of Ferraris it's nothing that
unrelatable it's the story of these two
men played by Matt Damon and Christian
Bale Carol Shelby and Ken miles and
they're gonna create the fastest car
that can possibly conceive of and create
and it's the creative process and I love
that I loved seeing it I loved the
performances in this movie
Matt Damon and Christian Bale both great
actors both great in this movie man
Christian Bale just steals all the
scenes first scene with him you're like
all right so you're just gonna crush it
this whole time shoo-in for an Academy
Award nomination I don't know I just I I
don't even see the world like the
Academy does but if I was to nominate a
Best Actor this year yeah I would
nominate him because he's the heart you
know you're rooting for both of these
dudes are both good people but Ken miles
Christian Bale's character he's the
heart in this movie because he's the
underdog because he's not the face that
Ford wants so they're kind of we're for
damn it we're class Ford you know what
that stands for [ __ ] over rebuilt
dodge class I tell ya we can't have him
being the face of our company doing this
race and that's really where the vs. is
you know it's creators versus the
company they're trying to Stonewall them
every chance they get they're trying to
micromanage the creative process and I
love that I can't praise the movie
enough about that because that story is
a story as old as time itself definitely
entertainment itself it's the way it was
then it's the way it was before then
it's the way it is now with YouTube and
the entertainment industry it's the way
it will always be going forward in the
future until Skynet takes over because
we're going back to when those movies
were good company wants to beat the
other company so they need to make a
product that's better than the other
company's products oh look at that there
are really talented people and they'll
do it for the love of it so we will use
them for our own means I love that the
movie makes the worry you're never
rooting for Ford it's never you don't
even care about the Ford versus Ferrari
thing you just want these guys to be
able to create the greatest car they can
they're rooting for them not the company
that seems to think they own them back
if you're going into this movie
expecting a racing movie you're gonna be
disappointed it's not about racing cars
which is great because I know nothing
about car racing everything I learned
about racing I learned from Mario Kart
sad to say I learned today red shells
are just not part of the equation
lucky for everyone spike shells aren't
either because those things are [ __ ]
but it's movie about creating
collaboration it's about these
characters you don't need to know a lot
about racing in order to enjoy Ford
versus Ferrari like you don't need to
know a lot about hip hop in order to
enjoy straight out of Compton you don't
need to know about catching ghosts or
being enthusiast of gozer the gozerian
in order to enjoy Ghostbusters because
it's about the spirit it's about the
characters they're who you root for
that's why you're rooting for this movie
in the first place also all the
supporting actors they were great too
because it was so well cast Josh Lucas
is in this movie who do you think he
plays yeah he plays a complete douchebag
for four who else would he play that's
exactly who he plays but he plays that
character well also ray McKinnon you
know ray McKinnon you don't think you
know ray McKinnon but you do because
he's that guy in a lot of things I love
the dude cuz he played Norris reg wick
in the needful things at apt Asians
Stephen King book like oh gods like the
summer after tenth grade I read that
book pick up the movie watch the movie
and I was like he is so perfect as
Norris reg wick that side character that
a lot of people probably won't remember
from the movie but damn it he was great
as him he was good
movie - I gotta give him love and it's
directed by James Mangold I believe it's
mangled and mangled or Mangold however
you want to enunciate but that's the
director of Logan also quite a few other
movies 3:10 to Yuma but Logan come on
point is Ford vs. Ferrari I heard good
things we all heard good things because
we always hear good things from people
coming out of film festivals and
premieres it's just the way gushing goes
but as it got closer to me watching this
movie it's kind of low-key became one of
my anticipated movies I was like I
really want to see this movie not only
did the movie not disappoint it exceeded
my expectations like I said if you're
going in looking for a racing movie
you're not gonna leave fulfilled
although I will say the end race in this
movie is amazing this exciting
nail-biting I was biting my nails
hardcore I mean I bite my nails anyway
but damn yeah I had to pee for like half
this movie never left ten miles is a
name I've never heard of and I feel like
I should because this movie presents him
he's like the Mozart of race cars he
just knows how a cars supposed to work
he's the embodiment of that speech
everyone gives in a movie Matt Damon
actually gives it in this movie where's
like you can get a racer anywhere but he
needs something else you know you need
heart it's someone who feels the car
he's that guy you know he's the guy who
truly does feel the car I'm kind of on a
high with this movie usually I err on
the side of caution like alright maybe
we'll just bust it down a little bit
I've been cautious about my awesome
tacular so you know what I'm going with
it today Ford vs. Ferrari is awesome
tacular
all right so Myles and Shelby versus
Ford is probably what the movie should
have been called have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's your
favorite movie about the creative spirit
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you wanna see more click right here to
see more
[Music]